Definitely what it is about
understanding
the role that
neighborhoods and spaces play in cities
as a lens to understand
public policy and approach more
efficient solutions, we have wasted a lot of time
designing solutions that are general
for cities when  In reality, we
realize that
education problems, health problems,
security problems
have very particular concentrations and manifestations
in
cities. I hope to see a more
important development of public policies based
precisely on the geographical application
of these policies in the future.  In a
specific case, for example, of the issues
you know, you have already been working on, such as
crime and urban violence,
we have understood that violence and
crime occur in a greater way or in a
concentrated way in some parts of
the cities
and if we are able to  design
strategies and tools that address
this  In places specifically, we will be
much more efficient in solving
these problems and not just
serving the city in general terms.